[Applaudissements]
qu'ils nous appellent
c'est boulot vous doutez bien sûr
ensemble jusqu'à lui
c'est la dure y va avec fouzi sommet
entendu vous nous appelez bien entendu
où nous exposer votre problème
on a tous crise a bien damien qui nous
appellent ça lui damien damien tabitha
mieux tu nous appelles doux damien
damien salut damien c'est quoi ton
problème
ouais tu étais ouais tu étais au mcdo
ouais t'as voulu ouais ouais ouais je
vois le genre ouais tu essaies de sortir
ton de gates
ils ont toujours des blast 2 salut c'est
gopher en détention sans déconner c'est
d'ailleurs une info du droit du bail et
à les remplacer camille combal étonnant
comme moi
il ya aussi sa maman plus value et manu
à la radio je vous le dis je ne rigole
pas franchement oui c'est le meilleur
hamel animateur radio marseillette la
radio mais il regarde c'est vrai que
c'est d'ailleurs étonnant parce que je
sais je sais c'est étonnant parce que je
suis pas sûr voilà que viennent tous les
jours le marin sommet sera très serré le
jeu lui souhaite beaucoup de succès
parce qu'il est très très bon manu voilà
et je peux vous dire à la radio où il va
moi je sais que voilà mais moi j'ai dit
foule malheureusement sur skyrock qui
offriront donc je suis obligé d'écouter
difool continue à écouter skyrock tous
les matins forcément je continuerai à
écouter skyrock parce que c'est le
frérot mais manu payet venir à bout
aussi mais voilà je serai toujours sur
des foules le matin et sur des foules le
soir d'ailleurs maudit foule tu sais que
je t'aime et tu sais que je sais que
j'ai un truc à vous dire sur 10 vous les
fait jamais de télé et il m'a promis
qu'à la rentrée bon anniversaire
il me fera une surprise il viendra le 23
s'est passé c'est pas une surprise en
fait
[Rires]